when i think about the current time
and i think about trump versus biden i'm
curious to know what you're going to say
to this
under a trump administration that we had
who were our top enemies during a trump
administration who were our top enemies
maybe
you're going to say china you're on
whatever the list may be from you but
i'm also curious to know what you think
now under a biden administration who our
top enemies are so trump administration
might administration what would you say
okay there's no doubt that the number
one adversary the united states has had
for a long time is communist china
uh it's an authoritarian country uh they
aim to be
the dominant party in the planet earth
number two would be iran
because the uncertainty as to whether
they're going to use the nuclear weapons
that they're building and they are
building nuclear weapons
and the icbms that they're testing just
did one year what four or five days ago
the fact is communist china is helping
make that happen why
because it's to their advantage to have
us distracted by other things
besides what's going on in communist
china kindness chinese
are today committing genocide against
the we are people
and others they're committing the kinds
of threats to
democracy that they promised to abide by
when the british signed the treaty
giving hong kong their ultimate you know
catastrophe
number three they're building literally
military bastions all over the south
china sea
by dredging up coral and building
runways and
arming them things that they said they'd
never do number four they're threatening
taiwan
this is just this past week we ended up
with the u.s navy
freedom of navigation exercise going
through the straits of taiwan in
which at least a half dozen maybe as
many as 10
different communist chinese aircraft
overflew that usa
the the u.s destroyer that was going
through the straits
those kinds of things say a lot about
where they're heading
they're also trying to dominate the
economy of the world
their so-called belt and road initiative
which takes
basically most of sub-saharan africa is
dominated today by communist china
yeah i mean i've been out there i've
seen
every time you go to a major city in
sub-saharan africa
you're looking at communist chinese
engineers and you're looking here in the
united states the communist chinese
military intelligence people coming to
our colleges and university
to steal our intellectual property much
of it has to do with things like weapons
with whom we deal very closely with
israel understandably the israelis are
very concerned
i mean we've got an impeachment trial
going on as you and i are speaking
where there's an impeachment trial going
on in washington dc
and at the same time one of america's
closest allies
bibi netanyahu is on trial in jerusalem
i mean we have never seen in my lifetime
i was born when
fdr was president okay we've never seen
in our lifetime
anything like this and on top of it a
pandemic a worldwide pandemic
that was actually supported by what the
communist chinese refused to do
and that was tell everybody how
communicable this terrible disease is
it's now mutating in south africa
in the so-called uk version of it we
have no idea
whether the the vaccines were developed
in such enormous rush
you know operational warp speed by
president trump we have no idea if these
things are going to protect us
from this new mutant variant of that
disease
was it developed in a chinese communist
lab god only knows
i don't know but i do know that they did
everything in their power to keep
us from finding out how communicable it
was how deadly it is
and the bottom line of it is the
communist chinese are behind
all that stuff and on top of that we've
got 60 or 70
of these so-called confucius institutes
co-located on american college
university
which are teaching communist chinese
ideology
and when you look at all of those things
the soft power the hard
power the kinds of military activities
there's no doubt coming is china
still the number one adversary does the
biden administration realize that
the only i know the call would be hunter
biden if you can get him on the show
he's probably making america's foreign
policy toward china
uh so so the reason why i asked this for
him is the following question because
so whether it's trump or whether it's
biden enemy number one enemy is the same
china number two enemy in your eyes same
iran
where do you go from there do you go or
do you go russia do you go
you know turkey because i know turkey is
an ally but turkey's a little too
powerful in the middle east and they're
kind of bullying
guys that are bigger than him what do
you russia what do you put other people
below iran
well look i mean what we've got to do is
count on our nato allies to stand up
and one trump reimposed the sanctions
the pressure against the iranian regime
aimed not at creating a war aimed at
bringing the people of iran to the point
where they say look
we need a regime change here it doesn't
need to be revolutionary
we just need to vote out the theocracy
that's running the country
running around into the dirt to continue
to maintain the
enormous expenditures that are required
to build nuclear weapons and the means
of delivering them
who's the number one target for iran
remember we are the great satan
but remember it's a lot closer to israel
and so israel has got to regard
themselves as the
most likely target if not their if not
the ultimate design
and what the united states needs to make
sure that we can do is
do the kinds of intellectual property
investigations
and research and development on the best
means of deterring that kind of attack
you know the our military doesn't exist
to fight wars
we need to be capable of fighting a war
and winning it but our military exists
to deter adversaries from doing bad
things to us
attacking our country it's been
successful that throughout the entire
cold war the president i was blessed to
serve
ronald reagan understood that you know
peace through strength was one of his
mottos and the idea of
making sure that the bad guys are not
doing bad things how about the old
expression trust but verify that's
ronald reagan that's what every
president needs to be able to do
trump did it very forcefully there's
there's no doubt that
president trump said things in a way
that i would not say them and probably
you wouldn't say them but the fact is
if you look at the policies both
domestically and internationally with
trump
he got native to stand up and start
paying her fair share he added countries
to the nato
umbrella if you will he's built
relationships in the middle east
that nobody ever thought was possible i
mean think about
arab countries who are willing to do a
peace deal
with israel impossible not so
and so what what i hope is that this
administration
is going to follow through on a number
of those things that president trump did
very very well
and i'm very concerned because a lot of
their top advisors
blinken sullivan those are the guys that
negotiated the so-called joint
plan of action dealing the so-called
iran deal
and of course america gave up billions
of dollars in hard cash and then
added to it uh billions more that
allowed the ch
it allowed the the heavily heavy weight
of what they were doing in terms of
their economy it allowed that heavy
weight to be taken off because communist
china is now
the number one purchaser of their oil
we've got to make sure that the
europeans follow through
on where they started out with president
trump whether you like trump or not
the fact is the things he did were
remarkable in terms of protecting the
american people
extended domestically to protecting our
border countries without borders are
countries
okay so the free flow of individuals
across borders
is not something that gives you
sovereignty over your territory and on
top of that
he rebuilt america's defenses he got us
out of an endless war in afghanistan
got us out of an endless war in iraq
pulled troops back
from places where they'd been for in
some cases decades but the bottom line
of it was all done to protect the
american people
and like i say deterrence is the number
one objective of a strong military
israel knows that we know that does
anybody else in this administration know
it besides you and me i hope so
so if you like this sort of short clip
from an interview i did click over here
to watch the entire
interview and please don't forget to
subscribe to the channel take care
everybody bye
[Music]